[Música]
desde hace algo más de un año escuchamos
todos los días no conversaciones que
giran en torno a la pandemia pareciera
que el mundo se ha vuelto loco que
realmente hemos nos hemos precipitado en
una especie de cataclismo global pero
realmente es así si uno mira en la
historia de la ciencia se da cuenta que
las epidemias y las bande mias son tan
antiguas como el ser humano puede
decirse que no ha habido prácticamente
un ser humano sobre la tierra que no le
haya tocado vivir a lo largo de su vida
un 'piso un episodio al menos de
pandemia y esto tiene que ver con el
hecho de que el ser humano es un ser
social y por lo tanto necesitamos de los
otros
las pandemias se hicieron
particularmente frecuentes desde hace
unos 10.000 años que se estableció la
agricultura y eso hizo que el ser humano
entrara en contacto directo con muchos
animales y de este modo se facilitaba el
contagio
ahora bien si los animales son parte del
problema son también parte de la
solución en la medida en que las vacunas
precisamente se producen a partir de los
animales
las pandemias han dejado una huella
importante en la historia las decisiones
que ha tomado el ser humano para
prevenirlas para enfrentarlas quedan
como registros no en nuestros
patrimonios y de nuestra realidad
por ejemplo a la hora de construir las
ciudades en el siglo 16 y 17 se recurría
a tratados de urbanismo que tenían muy
en cuenta el hecho de evitar las
pandemias de este modo se hacían por
ejemplo calles muy ventiladas se
cuidaban mucho la orientación de las
calles se creaban grandes plazas y
patios que facilitaban la ventilación y
evitaban la concentración de muchas
personas
otro aspecto otra huella que nos ha
dejado esta respuesta del ser humano
para defenderse de las pandemias
encontramos en los cementerios ahora nos
resulta común que los cementerios se
encuentran fuera de las ciudades sin
embargo en el siglo 16 y 17 los
cementerios se encontraban pegados a los
atrios en la ciudad y los muertos se
enterraban muy pocos prácticamente se
dejaban en la superficie porque se creía
que de ese modo sus almas llegaban antes
al cielo
para prevenir las pandemias se tomó la
decisión de primero desplazar los
cementerios a las afueras de las
ciudades y luego sacarlos de los atrios
y finalmente enterrarlos a varios metros
bajo tierra eso en su momento generó un
colapso social y mucha preocupación
porque las personas que enterraban a sus
seres queridos sentían que sus almas
quedaban más cerca del y que era
más difícil garantizar su salvación
las pandemias han generado a lo largo de
la historia mucho pánico si alguno
quiere poco ver no cómo viven las
pandemias por ejemplo en la edad media o
en el renacimiento pues es muy
interesante la película de imán berman
el séptimo sello ahí se ve no como las
personas realmente sentían un pánico y
muchas veces llegaban a las pandemias
con el fin del mundo en realidad es
desde hace relativamente poco algo más
de 100 años que tenemos una explicación
científica de las pandemias hoy en día
sabemos que las pandemias son producidas
por microorganismos
y que esos microorganismos se contagien
eso ha permitido que el ser humano
también tú pudiera tomar decisiones y
tener cierto control sobre los contagios
entre las diferentes
aportaciones de la ciencia para
prevenirla las pandemias están por
ejemplo las vacunas que se crearon a
finales del siglo 18 las pandemias
también han permitido el desarrollo de
la ciencia y con ese desarrollo nos han
permitido conocer mejor por ejemplo los
virus los que conocíamos muy poquitos de
hace poco todavía hoy en día hay dudas
sobre se considera los virus como seres
vivos o como no seres vivos su tamaño es
tan pequeño y tan difícil de estudiar
que si juntáramos todos los virus del
planeta
que habrían de sobra en una pequeña lata
de refrescos hoy en día por ejemplo
sabemos que los enemigos no son siempre
negativos o malos sino que los videos
fueron fundamentales para la evolución
de las especies todos nosotros es decir
los mamíferos 18 por ciento de nuestro
código genético desde nuestro genoma
está formado por virus que se quedaron a
vivir dentro de nuestras células y
algunos de ellos permanecen activos por
ejemplo la formación de la placenta o
incluso la formación de ciertos músculos
tiene que ver con la expresión genética
de esos virus que quedaron atrapados
digamos en nuestras células
también nos ha ayudado a comprender
muchísimo mejor el sistema inmunológico
el que prácticamente sabíamos muy
poquito hasta hace poco el sistema
inmunológico es fundamental porque es la
forma natural que tiene el organismo
para protegerse de cualquier
microorganismo
en este sentido la pandemia nos ha
demostrado como el sistema inmunológico
es un arma
es fundamental lo que hay que tomar en
cuenta a la hora de protegerse de las
infecciones o de las pandemias por eso
si por ejemplo uno descuida su sistema
inmunológico por la alimentación o
simplemente porque se queda aislado o no
y no tiene un contacto con la realidad
ese sistema inmunológico se hace más
frágil y también es más es más difícil
luchar contra las pandemias
la actual pandemia ha permitido ciertos
desarrollos científicos gracias al
trabajo colaborativo de grupos de
investigación de buena parte del mundo
que han significado varios
descubrimientos muy interesantes para la
ciencia uno de ellos por ejemplo es un
tipo de vacuna bastante eficaz que se
conoce como las vacunas a rn mensajeros
las vacunas tradicionales lo que hacen
es meter dentro del organismo mediante
una inyección microorganismos patógenos
pero inactivos para que el propio cuerpo
pueda generar las defensas de tal modo
que cuando llega el microorganismo vivo
las defensas ya están preparadas para
vencerlo las vacunas estas vacunas
nuevas de arne mensajero no meten el
microorganismo sino que simplemente lo
que hacen es agarrar una pequeña parte
de su código genético
es el que produce el que tiene la
información para las proteínas que
permiten fijar el virus a las células
del ser humano entonces quedan sólo con
esa parte y la producen la multiplican
dentro de la célula para que de ese modo
nuestro cuerpo quede en capacidad de
reconocer no el microorganismo entero
sino esa proteína es fácil de explicar
mediante el siguiente ejemplo imagínense
que en lugar de un virus tuviéramos un
toro delante
las vacunas tradicionales implicarían
inactivar al toro y meterlo dentro para
que nuestro cuerpo se reconociera con él
y pudiera luchar en su contra tan pronto
apareciera vivo sin embargo estas nuevas
vacunas lo que hacen es fijarse en esa
parte particularmente peligrosa los
cuernos por ejemplo no se quedan con
esos cuernos los meten dentro producen
muchos cuernos como si fueran panfletos
que se reparten por toda la célula y por
todo el cuerpo para que nuestras pop el
sistema nuestras células que se encargan
de la defensa aprendan a reconocer al
toro por los cuernos de tal manera que
cuando aparece el toro nuestras células
ya están preparadas y los reconocen
enseguida e insisto por sus cuernos
esto podría ser una responder a la
pregunta de si las pandemias son o no
son inevitables
realmente hemos visto que las pandemias
es algo que acompañan al ser humano
desde sus comienzos ahora bien la
ciencia nos da ciertos elementos para
poder reducir los efectos catastróficos
que pueden tener sobre las poblaciones
humanas es también muy importante que no
descuidemos el hecho de que las
pandemias pueden también producir
ciertas brechas sociales en la medida en
que no toda la población tengan la
oportunidad de disponer los medicamentos
o los elementos que permitan protegerse
contra las pandemias por eso algo que
también pone sobre la mesa de las
pandemia sobre la mesa las pandemias es
ese elemento social del ser humano que
tenemos que aprender a defender con la
solidaridad